ambassade de France auprès du Saint
Siège la nouvelle vient de tomber
le conseiller de l'ambassadeur
Jean-Philippe Thiais déjà sur le pont et
prévient tout le monde
Laurent c'est Jean-Philippe bon tu sais
tout j'ai besoin de rien te dire
ah bon d'accord et ben oui le pape le
pape est décédé à 21h37
on a commencé à le savoir aux alentours
de 22h15
ils ont vraiment fait n'importe quoi
ça a été annoncé un journaliste avant
d'être annoncé officiellement
Hugues un des deux policiers que compte
l'ambassade de France au Vatican met le
drapeau en berne comme le veut le
protocole
j'ai eu personne à Matignon mais je
pense que l'ambassadeur a fait tout ça
en fait mais l'ambassadeur rentre de
dîner là il est pas encore
arrivé de l'ambassadeur qui a dû quitter
son dîner il est passé prendre sa
secrétaire sur le chemin
on ne prévoit jamais comme il faut
parfaitement
l'ambassadeur retrouve son conseiller
qui depuis le début de la soirée informe
l'Élysée
j'en ai des morceaux mais
on vous vous en avez pour longtemps
encore est-ce que vous voulez que je
décrive tout précisément vous êtes assez
précis
le message officiel et puisqu'on en sait
oui ok j'arrive dans cinq minutes
à Paris tout ce qui ne pouvait pas
envoyer tant que la nouvelle n'était pas
sortie et qui maintenant va qu'on a
commencé à préparer qu'on va préciser en
fonction des dernières éléments qu'on a
et de façon à ce que Paris est un peu
tout le mode d'emploi sur la façon dont
ça va se passer dans les prochains jours
si vous pouvez essayer de me préparer
une note verbale qui reprend ça c'est
celle de 78 donc vous collez plus ou
moins sur le modèle enfin bon vous
essayez de nettoyer déjà
on essaie de la porter l'urgence rédiger
les condoléances du président français
aux autorités du Vatican un texte écrit
à partir du dernier exemple un
communiqué daté de 27 ans signé alors de
la main de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
c'était pour la mort de Jean-Paul 1er
les journées qui viennent vont être
chargées pour l'ambassadeur et son
équipe dans quelques jours c'est eux qui
devront accueillir la délégation
française
à partir de ce soir l'ambassadeur doit
jouer de son influence et de ses
relations pour que les cardinaux et
lisent un pape proche des positions de
la France surtout en politique étrangère
comme Jean-Paul dele a été en condamnant
la guerre américaine en Irak alors pour
les condoléances au Vatican le diplomate
pèse déjà chaque virgule
[Musique]
chaque mois son importance on essaye
d'être précis vous savez c'est quelque
chose qui est
finalement très important le flou ça
peut faire ensuite des complications
pour vous donner un peu une idée sur
l'aspect concret si vous voulez les
outils il y a la nuit à pontificale ça
c'est intéressant faudrait que vous le
vous le consultiez c'est une espèce de
d'annuaire qui dit tout sur le
fonctionnement de l'église et donc là
dans tout ce qu'on envoie pour enseigner
Paris il faut vérifier les dates il faut
être sûr qu'on sait pas trompé les dates
de naissance les nationalités ce que les
les cardinaux faut bien les connaître
maintenant chacun d'eux et détient la
souveraineté de l'église tous ensemble
c'est et donc ils ont ils ont tous un
avis un homme une voix au Vatican le
pape n'est pas encore enterré que les
grandes manœuvres ont déjà commencé
originaire des pays riches ou des pays
pauvres intégristes ou progressistes
jeunes ou vieux 115 cardinaux tous
potentiellement éligibles vont arriver
dès demain du monde entier pour nommer
le successeur de Jean-Paul II
officiellement ils vont choisir en leur
année conscience mais déjà tous les
grandes ce monde s'apprêtent à les
courtiser pour tenter d'influencer leur
vote
[Musique]
Rome le lendemain matin
des milliers de pèlerins convergent vers
la place Saint-Pierre une foulimense est
déjà massée sous les fenêtres des
appartements ou reposant corps la
dépouille du parc
Marco Poletti lui est là pour travailler
c'est un des hommes les mieux informés
du Vatican journaliste dans un grand
journal italien il passe son temps à
décrypter les arcanes de l'église il est
ce qu'on appelle un vaticaniste les 115
cardinaux électeurs se retrouveront en
conclave et voteront deux fois par jour
jusqu'à décider qui d'entre eux sera le
chef
c'est clair que
la date du conclave alors c'est le 18
avril alors c'est très intéressant parce
que ça veut dire que les cardinaux ont
décidé de faire vite
de ne pas laisser passer trop tard
et aujourd'hui comment une
une période de presque 10 jours très
serré
des contacts des conservation des
conversations
qui seront
derrière les coulisses
tout se passe les vraies choses se
passent derrière les coulisses
et surtout ce sont généralement
[Musique]
des petits repas des petits
conversations
et généralement il n'y a pas même le
secrétaire d'un cardinaux et l'autre
c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un secret
à quelques minutes de la place
Saint-Pierre
l'église Saint-Louis des Français le
quartier général des catholiques
francophones à Rome ce dimanche matin se
loupé le maître des lieux s'en
souviendra simple prêtre il officiait à
la place de Monseigneur beaucardo le
secrétaire général de la Cité du Vatican
en personne Monseigneur Max gloupait a
dû remplacer au pied levé se proche du
pape des fins pour célébrer la
confirmation de deux de ses fidèles
prévues
[Musique]
au nom du Père et du Fils et du
Saint-Esprit
frère et sœur
c'est dans la peine
que son au coeurs aujourd'hui après le
départ du Saint-Père qui depuis des mois
savait parfaitement que la rencontre
allait s'approcher elle est venue
soyons dans la paix
comme lui est parti dans la sérénité et
dans la joie si Max gloupet se
rappellera longtemps de ce jour c'est
aussi parce que pendant quelques heures
il a dû garder un secret un secret
partagé par peu de personnes au Vatican
et que lui a confié la veille celui
qu'il remplace le cardinal Boccardo
[Musique]
et vous ont prévenu quand dans la nuit
on vous a dit quoi c'était elle m'a dit
le Pape
sera mort dans une heure il m'a appelé
hier soir à 8h30 et je peux pas venir
alors il a téléphoné au cardinal Ruini
pour que celui-ci lui donne des pouvoirs
[Musique]
à l'église Saint-Louis des Français le
centre d'accueil de la paroisse nous
sommes au coeur de la sphère d'influence
de l'épiscopat français au Vatican avec
la mort du pape et le début des grandes
manoeuvres pour sa succession la maison
de Max gloupet est devenue un endroit
stratégique et très prisé par le clergé
français
une chambre oui tu en veux combien
moi j'ai un certain Lustiger qui a été
Vex chez vous oui
mais il a une chambre ici et quand j'ai
dit à sa secrétaire mais il va aller
loger à Sainte-Marthe elle va dire NON
NON jusqu'au conclave
une ou deux pas beaucoup
mais
Dieu
allez ciao
Monseigneur lui stigé est le premier
cardinal français arrivé à Rome en tout
ils seront 5 à voter réformistes mais
très respecté par les conservateurs
c'était un proche de Jean-Paul II son
influence est grande et les autorités
françaises espèrent pouvoir compter sur
lui pour faire entendre leur voix
je vais auprès du pape
depuis quelques heures la dépouille de
Jean-Paul II est exposée au public un
public pour l'instant encore trié sur le
volet seuls les diplomates et les
religieux de Oran ont leur ticket
d'entrée
max Clouet lui suit les cérémonies à
distance
on a arrêté
le service à cause de lui
la France peut pas avoir de Pape
je vois pas lequel mais
c'est pas
c'est pas possible
celui qui pourrait l'être
c'est
maintenant il est trop âgé
il y a 78 ans
et puis
trop personnel et trop original
il n'entre pas facilement dans les
canons
au même moment en France à Lyon
un autre des cinq cardinaux français qui
vont prendre part au vote s'apprête à
célébrer une messe en hommage à
Jean-Paul II dans la cathédrale
Saint-Jean ce cardinal c'est lui
Philippe Barbarin à 54 ans c'est un des
plus jeunes cardinaux du futur conclave
mais aussi un des plus conservateurs
rond dans les manières mais plutôt carré
sur les principes il doit sa carrière
fulgurante à Jean-Paul II
j'espère oui enfin c'est surtout eux qui
vont prier pour moi donc on a choisi
c'est un bon il faut que jusqu'à
tâche Philippe Barbarin compte sur le
perv Vincent féroldi son fidèle
directeur de la communication
je vous dis bonjour de tout mon coeur et
je reviens mais spécialement
vous nous faites d'abord mais un grand
merci pour tout ce que le pape que Dieu
comme geste fraternité à l'égard de
notre communauté il repose en paix dans
le jardin d'Eden et que vous-même vous
ayez
l'Esprit de sainteté pour choisir le
meilleur pape qui soit pour l'humanité à
moins que ce soit vous-même et je
l'exclut pas il y a pas de risque
c'est au cours des Journées Mondiales de
la Jeunesse que Jean-Paul II a repéré
Philippe Barbarin 7 ans plus tard il le
nommait cardinal alors c'est par une
phrase de son père spirituel qu'il a
choisi de conclure son homélie
l'amour de se contente pas de regarder
engagez-vous
accomplissez votre mission qu'on viendra
l'heure de votre génération
c'est sur cette phrase frères et sœurs
que je voudrais terminer parce que je la
trouve belle parce qu'elle a été
prononcée ici à Lyon parce qu'elle
s'adresse à la génération qui monte et
parce qu'elle lui dit toute l'espérance
que nous mettons en elle l'amour
ne se contente pas de regarder lève-toi
et marche
merci Monsieur Barbarin est réputé
proche d'un des cardinaux conservateurs
les plus en vus dans la course à la
succession le cardinal Scola
un italien en voilà du bon monde vous
motorisez juste à boire un verre d'eau
avant vous êtes super
et ben dis donc c'était beau Monsieur le
Chanoine vous êtes content
c'est bien
ah d'accord
Cola le cardinal de Venise un nom que
pour l'instant Monseigneur se refuse à
donner
voilà est-ce que vous avez tous l'accord
de Monsieur férol si vous avez l'accord
de pervers moi c'est oui
vous savez pour qui vous allez voter
mais je vais peut-être changer d'avis
pendant les 15 jours sergent avec une
idée indésir que dans mon coeur depuis
longtemps mais évidemment comme il y a
15 jours de concertation
je verrai peut-être qu'il y a mieux que
ce que je pense c'est je suis tout à
fait prêt à changer d'avis
merci à vous tous quant à son éventuel
candidature sont chargés en
communication à une réponse toute faite
élu quelqu'un du mal approche des 55 ans
les jeunes faut peut-être laisser le
temps de mûrir
retour à Rome à l'église Saint-Louis des
Français
c'est l'heure du déjeuner pour tous les
pensionnaires du séminaire et du Fils et
du Saint-Esprit depuis deux jours max
loupé à une place réservée à ses côtés
[Musique]
pendant du Père et du Fils et du
Saint-Esprit
[Musique]
le visiteur qu'on attend ici
c'est le cardinalustigé il revient du
Vatican
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
c'était aujourd'hui la première réunion
préparatoire au conclables qui
rassemblait les cardinaux déjà arrivés à
Rome une congrégation dans le langage
des cardinaux l'occasion de tester
quelques noms et de tenter quelques
rapprochements
les passionné
son attention à tout ce qu'on fait
mais de cela personne ne souffle mot à
table le cardinal Lustiger reste plus
muet qu'une carte
il dit rien il sait tout il dit rien il
a commencé le repas comme ça
avait été bonne il m'a dit je peux même
pas répondre ça
voilà alors
secret absolu
ce qui se passe dans des grands
cardinaux on n'a pas à savoir ce qui
s'est passé
c'est le secret du Vatican
[Musique]
on en saura pas plus
max gloupet lui continue à accueillir
ses eaux
alors vous avez fait bon voyage très bon
sauf que nous avons échappé à une bombe
ah bon c'est une alerte à la bombe à
l'aéroport de Rome après le cardinal du
stigier c'est au tour du cardinal honoré
l'archevêque et mérite de tours de
prendre ses quartiers à Saint-Louis des
Français
alors vous n'êtes pas cardinal
est titulaire était là était arrivé
le cardinal honoré sera présent pendant
toute la durée du conclave mais il ne
votera pas
voilà
ayant passé l'âge des 80 ans
ce serait dans la coulisse vous dites ça
avec cocatrie parce que personne ne le
croit
même nombreux une influence oui parce
que on se fait une pignon enfin on
rencontre les uns et les autres et puis
on mûrit un peu si vous voulez le profil
que pourrait avoir le futur pape le
cardinal Honoré est arrivé
et il se trouve juste en face au numéro
05 si vous voulez
le cardinalustigier n'a pas vu son
collègue et a mis depuis longtemps
Monseigneur cloupé a bien fait les
choses ils sont maintenant voisins
et vont pouvoir converser entre
cardinaux à l'abri des oreilles
indiscrètes
au Vatican la dépouille du pape n'est
toujours pas accessible aux communs des
fidèles
passe une tenue
un peu plus conforme avec
l'esprit du moment
un moment donné la chemise bleue pour la
chemise blanche mettre une corde un peu
plus sombre voilà c'est pas la c'est pas
la grande tenue des cérémonies
officielles qui est la vie et que depuis
mais bon je présente pas devant le pape
qu'une chemise bleue
Jean-Philippe qui elle est le conseiller
de l'ambassade va profiter d'un message
qu'il doit porter en main propre au
Vatican pour s'incliner devant le pape
des fins
pour l'occasion il se remplace Saint
Pierre accompagné de son épouse c'est un
privilège au lendemain de la mort du
souverain les membres du corps
diplomatique et leur famille peuvent
aller se recueillir devant le catafalque
problème les curieux et les fidèles qui
espèrent eux aussi pouvoir rendre un
dernier hommage à Jean-Paul II se presse
déjà à l'entrée de la basilique il faut
réussir à rentrer
en fait on va essayer de rentrer par la
porte de bronze mais c'est justement à
ce moment là qu'à mon avis il faut
couper à Bordeaux c'est là-bas c'est
l'entrée officiel des des visiteurs de
marque et
les carabiniers laissent passer
Jean-Philippe et sa femme
pas notre caméra
l'ambassadeur lui aussi se rend au
Vatican la rumeur court à Rome le
prochain pape serait italien et
conservateur Pierre Morel doit profiter
de sa visite pour glaner des infos à ce
sujet il ne s'est pas encore si le
président Chirac sera le chef de la
délégation mais il s'est capable on va
lui demander des éléments précis sur
cette rumeur
le chef de la délégation la Haute
Autorité française qui vient
arrive dans ce dans ce que vous verrez
aussi qui sera extraordinaire il sait en
gros ce qui se passe
parce qu'on peut pas donner tous les
détails il faut il faut sélectionner sur
il faut aller à l'essentiel si vous
voulez et la tendance la tendance à dire
la photo la photo et la tendance la
tendance est ce qu'on se dit que ce sera
plutôt en Italie tout le monde tout le
monde dit ça mais il faut pondérer
énormément de choses surtout pas de
simplisme en moment c'est le meilleur
moyen pour se tromper
il faut pas tomber là dedans et puis pas
tomber là-dedans de contrefeu allumer de
tout ça et plein de détours si vous
voulez
ça c'est c'est le cœur du métier de
l'ambassade
l'ambassadeur rentre à titre officiel au
Saint Siège cette porte est la frontière
entre la ville de Rome et l'État du
Vatican nous décidons de rester dans la
voiture et de continuer à filmer c'est
l'occasion pour nous de pénétrer en
cachette dans la Cité Interdite alors
nous allons parce qu'il y a plusieurs
entrées quand on entre la basilique
l'entrée c'est ce que vous allez voir là
la porte Sainte-Marthe le bâtiment de
Sainte-Marthe c'est là qu'on habiter les
cardinaux
et ils vont tous être là les casinos qui
viennent du monde entier tout ça c'est
l'hôtel des cardinaux alors là c'est
quand les cérémonies c'est la petite
porte qui est sous la et là nous allons
nous passons cette partie pour rejoindre
ce qu'on appelle l'arc des cloches l'arc
odela campagne et c'est là que je vais
je vais descendre pour rejoindre le
parvis et et vous à partir de ce
moment-là bonne chance et
aucun tournage n'est autorisé ici nous
sommes rentrés ni vu ni connu
et là je vous laisse allez merci à tout
à l'heure
Vatican nous en profitons pour nous
glisser avec notre mini caméra parmi les
chauffeurs l'instant est privilégié nous
nous permettons une petite visite
discrète nous croisons les futurs
électeurs du pape qui se font les
premières civilités les appartements
privés du souverain côté court la
résidence Sainte-Marthe où seront logés
tous les cardinaux pendant le Conclave
un bâtiment tout confort construit à la
demande de Jean-Paul II mais nous ne
nous attarderons pas le périmètre et
truffé de caméra de surveillance
retour place Saint-Pierre
pour les fidèles et les touristes il
faut se contenter de suivre le
recueillement des diplomates sur écran
géants en attendant l'ouverture au
public l'ambiance sur la place est
festive au Vatican c'est une toute autre
partition qui se joue autour de la
dépouille nous retrouvons le conseiller
de l'ambassade à sa sortie
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui
sont
tout l'entourage du Saint-Siège donc les
employés
la famille pontificale
donc il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde
beaucoup d'Italiens majorité
donc on fait la queue certains font
moins la queue que d'autres et puis il y
a des ministres qui arrivent en flux
assez régulier et les ministres
italiennes
cela n'a échappé à aucun diplomate il y
a des politiques beaucoup de politiques
italiens Silvio Berlusconi et ses
ministres se sont déplacés en nombre la
rumeur d'un complot des conservateurs
italiens semble se confirmer
[Musique]
Pierre Morel notre ambassadeur et lui de
retour du Saint Siège il convoque son
conseiller ecclésiastique un prêtre
rémunéré par l'État une particularité de
cette chancellerie l'ambassadeur lui
aussi a remarqué l'effervescence des
Italiens et veut vérifier un tuyau glané
dans les couloirs du Vatican
autre personne sur lequel il faut que
vous vous renseignez
c'est assez méconversations
voilà Sardi alors Sardi est un perso
important ça il faudrait que vous
ajoutiez au portrait c'est apparemment
le vice camerlingue le camerlingue c'est
le papa intérime celui qui règle les
affaires courantes en attendant
l'élection Paolo Sardy et son bras droit
quelqu'un qu'il faut absolument jauger
qui est-il un allié de la France ou un
proche des conservateurs italiens Sardi
a été enfin sa fonction principale
jusqu'à maintenant c'était d'être un des
principaux rédacteurs des projets de
discours du parrain
donc si vous voulez riche expérience
on va on va regarder un peu ce qu'on a
sur lui
Sardi apparemment né en 1934
en tenir 58
archevêque donc non sapostolique il est
rattaché voilà c'est intéressant c'est
qu'il est rattaché à la
disons au cabinet de la de la secrétaire
pourquoi vous en direz
cardinal c'est un archevêque simplement
parce qu'il est VICE camerounais
forcément il est l'adjoint donc on
essaie de d'approfondir un peu nos
indications à son sujet on peut intégrer
ces quelques éléments dans le télégramme
qui raconte la journée je trouve c'est
ça qui est mieux
c'est ça qui est le mieux
ce que j'ai entendu dire on m'a expliqué
c'est lui il vise caberlingue et il est
très actif bon bah on intègre et on fait
une confiance qui nous l'a dit c'est
de très bonnes sources quelqu'un qui le
connaît bien donc bon ça permet de
présenter
la fille signalétique de Monseigneur
Sardi arrivera le soir même à Paris
pour en savoir plus sur ce fameux
complot des conservateurs italiens nous
retrouvons Marco Poletti notre
vaticaniste il veut tenter de nous faire
rentrer là où le pouvoir s'exerce au
cœur de l'administration du Vatican qui
reste largement aux mains des
conservateurs
qui s'occupent des ici après 27 ans de
papes polonais nombreux sont ceux qui
espèrent maintenant voir élire un
nouveau pape italien voilà alors c'est
une grande c'est une grande
concentration de demande Signori des
évêques des clergé
mais évidemment pour Marco le
vaticaniste les intrigromènes sont plus
subtiles contre l'imagine à décrypter et
à pas une lobby le
pro pape italien parce que parmi les
Italiens parce que les Italiens sont
très divisés alors il y a des Italiens
qui voudraient qu'il y a un pape de
l'Amérique latine et peut-être un
secrétaire d'État italien parce que si
on a une pape de l'Amérique latine on
réforme moins la curie alors par exemple
la Curie est très internationaliste
dans l'avion qui l'emmène à Rome le
jeune poulain de l'Église de France
Monseigneur Barbarin toujours flanqué de
son directeur de la communication
s'apprête à découvrir avec appétit les
jeux du Vatican
on parle beaucoup de du poids des
Italiens par leur sur-représentation
même
il y a toujours beaucoup plus italien
que d'autres avant c'était
incroyablement disproportionné
maintenant non quand même vous avez pas
l'impression qu'ils ont ils font une
force de lobby je dirais
[Musique]
probablement mais moi
je n'ai pas senti encore
bon je ne sais pas mais c'est bien
possible
certainement quand je vais sentir c'est
c'est combats ces affrontements l'avoir
c'est normal c'est humain c'est un enjeu
énorme donc je serai pas étonné qu'il y
ait des tensions de ce genre ça m'affole
pas c'est une c'est une décision humaine
la décision humaine en toute
la grandeur de leurs enjeux y compris
spirituelle et en même temps leur
rudesse
dans l'épaisseur
[Musique]
du même voir ton rituel
le pied à peine posé à Rome le cardinal
est rapidement mis dans l'ambiance
bienvenue à Rome tu vois comment on est
accueilli gentiment
dans les milieux conservateurs italiens
il veut le prévenir des manœuvres qu'il
redoute dans les prochains jours à Rome
en aparté bien sûr et là le tout jeune
cardinal Barbarin on a encore à
apprendre sur le maniement du secret et
des micros sans fil des équipes télé
forcément ça se sait et dans la vie
attention tu as débranché ton truc il y
a pas débranché
pour un instant Monseigneur barbare un
fera bouche cousue
à la porte des arrivées de l'aéroport
les VIP en soutane se succèdent des
rassemblements comme celui qui se
prépare il n'y en a pas eu depuis
l'élection de Jean-Paul II il y a 27 ans
les chefs de toutes les églises
catholiques du monde convergent ce
jour-là voici mon Seigneur agréé le
cardinal de Côte d'Ivoire 79 ans
le papa est parti et on s'enfuit
de ta vie de qui est lourd à
que vous allez le combler le vide
bientôt
le Saint-Esprit nous aidera comblé ce
vide
parce que
nous faudra un bon pas pour la
chrétienté pour le monde tout le monde
attend tout le monde attend
mais le Saint-Esprit il y a déjà choisi
son
ce que j'appelle son joker il va le
sortir
face au poids des Européens il est un
des espoirs des églises africaines mais
l'Afrique ne compte que 11 cardinaux
électeurs sur les 115 qui vont voter
il y a beaucoup de gens qui évoquent la
possibilité un jour que qu'il y ait
peut-être un pape africain vous pensez
que c'est possible
bon
jusqu'ici ça n'a pas été le cas merci le
bon Dieu décidait que c'était le cas il
faudrait simplement s'interroger si nos
frères dans le monde nos frères
occidentaux
accepteraient psychologiquement et
spirituellement un pape [__]
est-ce que
psychologiquement et
spirituellement on est prêt à cette
révolution
c'est pas moi qui peut répondre
que pensez-vous dans votre cœur
Monseigneur ce que je pense à mon cas
moi je suis ouvert on est prêt ou pas
dessus ouvert
moi je suis ouvert mais vous
ça fait 15 heures que je voyage je suis
vieux
[Musique]
mais la meilleure chance du tiers-monde
c'est une autre église l'église
d'Amérique du Sud une église
progressiste qui conviendrait bien à la
France aujourd'hui un catholique sur
deux vit en Amérique latine 500 millions
de personnes
[Musique]
nous sommes au séminaire qui forment les
prêtres réputés les plus prometteurs du
continent latino tous ils sont destinés
à devenir évêques ou cardinaux
[Musique]
sous l'autorité d'un colombien de
Medellin le père londonio le père
spirituel du séminaire
au mur
une partie de nos étudiants vient
d'Argentine
ceci viennent d'Uruguay du Paraguay cela
du Chili cela vienne d'Équateur et cela
de Colombie
loin de l'atmosphère de Saint-Louis des
Français l'ambiance ici est plutôt
libérée on pourrait presque dire
coquine
non non
[Musique]
c'est sûr nous célébrons la messe avec
joie en chantant mais ici en Europe la
culture est différente les églises sont
vides quad chez nous les célébrations
sont chaudes animales sensuelles
un jour l'un de ces jeunes prêtres sera
peut-être pas une révolution aussi
importante que l'élection d'un polonais
il y a 27 ans
on parle pas des médicaments
et dans beaucoup de domaines au niveau
politique ou économique
comme Jean-Paul II il a beaucoup aidé la
Pologne
il a beaucoup aidé son pays
je ne crois pas que cette fois-ci le
pape se Rachid américain mais un jour ou
l'autre il y aura un pape sud-américain
c'est possible problème majeur l'église
sud-américaine s'est aussi la théologie
de la libération une église ouverte au
mariage des prêtres et à l'engagement
politique une église qui a été
marginalisée pendant 20 ans par
Jean-Paul II en clair une église peu en
odeur de sainteté au
Vaticano le Saint-Esprit va avoir
beaucoup de travail à faire dans ce
groupe
beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d'engagement du Saint-Esprit tu
as une peigne
parce que il faut que je vous dise
quelque chose
dans l'église aussi et l'appétit de
pouvoir est terrible oui
pour l'ambassadeur de France Pierre
Morel et sa femme à trois jours de
l'enterrement du Souverain Pontife les
nouvelles se précipitent c'est Paris qui
appelle
bon alors c'est le nouveau dispositif ça
dans un premier temps ils avaient parlé
de sécurité et bien on refait le point
en remontant merci
bon
anime toi de courage le président
arrivera presque certainement jeudi soir
donc
et lui est à la résidence avec sa suite
étroite tout le reste on lance des
dizaines et 10 et 20 chambres pour
précurseurs délégation etc
très bien je peux lancer les brioches de
brasses
toutes ces épreuves qui s'annoncent ne
font pas l'affaire de notre ambassadeur
son agenda est surchargé son objectif
n'a pas varié défendre la position de la
France pour faire barrage aux forcing
des néoconservateurs italiens qu'il
craint rendez-vous a été pris à
Saint-Louis des Français la paroisse de
Max gloupet après avoir fait passer son
message au cardinal Barbarin
l'ambassadeur veut parler de ses
craintes au cardinales lustigier qu'il
s'est proches du premier cercle du
pouvoir au Vatican
[Musique]
bien sûr d'abord il faut passer par une
messe
[Musique]
nous verrons tout particulièrement bien
sûr pour les nuises pour le pape
après l'office l'ambassadeur va tenter
d'avoir un aparté avec mon Seigneur
lustigier
mais il y a trop de caméra
ils conviennent alors d'un rendez-vous
plus discret
le temps
comme convenu
l'entretien terminé Max cloop est
propose de ramener l'ambassadeur à sa
voiture mais celui-ci lui redonne de
rester auprès de son cardinal
[Musique]
depuis la mort du pape les règles de
l'étiquette ont changé il a dit que je
n'avais pas ça le ramener à sa voiture
parce que du fait que le pape est mort
tous les cardinaux sont souverains et
donc je dois m'occuper du souverain
avant de m'occuper d'un ambassade
c'est le spirituel qui prime sur le
temporel ah non ils sont souveraineté
l'État du Vatican
mais ça veut dire que politiquement un
cardinal et
au-dessus
collégiale qui fait la fierté de
Monseigneur lustigé
vous êtes un des membres d'une direction
collégienne
collégiale ça n'a pas été inventé par le
parti pour l'URSS mais c'est inventé
déjà depuis longtemps par par l'Église
pour le gouvernement de l'église
mais là il y a pas de ça c'est ça le
problème
[Musique]
à plus
alors que Saint-Pierre se réveille
l'arrivée imminente du président Chirac
va ramener l'ambassadeur Morel à des
considérations plus terre à terre mais
tout aussi stratégique que l'émergence
d'un complot conservateur au Vatican
réunion à l'ambassade des Pays-Bas le
pays qui gouverne aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne ce qui préoccupe
l'ambassadeur c'est de savoir qui fait
le déplacement chez les autres européens
pour la France il va falloir tenir son
rang lors des obsèques qui s'annoncent
oui juste bien
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
le vendredi tu vas mettre l'uniforme
je crois que normalement je vais être
avec le président
est en retard bloqué par la foule désolé
d'être en retard
c'est quand on habite le plus près que
c'est le plus difficile d'être à l'heure
on arrive même plus à traverser les rues
un peu plus bas une marée humaine
entoure l'immeuble les voitures sont
encerclées par la foule Rome est devenu
impraticable même aux officiels les
chauffeurs sont obligés de donner un
coup de main au carabiniers pour dégager
le chemin et préparer la sortie des
ambassadeurs
fin de réunion coup de fil à l'Elysée
pour rendre compte
l'ambassadeur a obtenu le détail des
délégations officielles des autres pays
européens lors de la cérémonie j'ai
toutes les présences les heures
d'arrivée etc donc ça c'était très utile
Italie ils savent pas mais il y aura
forcément un parlementaire
Roumanie Premier ministre éventuellement
le président
mis à culture Bulgarie
président mise à faire étrangères
Espagne le roi la reine le Premier
ministre mis à faire étrangère chef de
l'opposition donc il y a un
parlementaire
voilà ce que j'ai pour le moment donc si
vous voulez
cette configuration fait que il me
paraît impossible de ne pas avoir le
président du Sénat dans les cinq le
Vatican a accordé que 5 places en
tribune officiel par pays problème c'est
beaucoup moins que prévu et ce n'est
visiblement pas négociable et mais
surtout ça peut apporte mais je veux
dire nous avons réessayé avec nos
meilleurs contacts qu'on connaît depuis
toujours au sein du système
écoutez la plus belle machine
diplomatique en temps normal qui est le
Saint Siège à disjoncter et donc on en
sortira pas parce que ils ne pourront
pas
entrer dans le moindre traitement
particulier
[Applaudissements]
autre façon de marquer son territoire
la méthode à la George Bush
[Applaudissements]
les Américains débarquent au Vatican
a une première dans la cité sainte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est-ce que j'en ai à faire de
bouche
pour est quand même rouler doucement
bouche pas à toute vitesse des dizaines
de véhicules hurlants avec radar
brouilleur service secret une
démonstration nous on est parqués comme
des moutons
les Américains
mais nous on est là on est parqués comme
des moutons
et en plus il rigole
quotidien la République le journal de
Marco Poletti c'est l'événement du jour
a pris tous les Européens de vitesse
pour venir se recueillir devant le corps
du pape d'autant qu'il n'est pas venu
seul deux anciens présidents et sa
secrétaire d'État la compagne
vous voyez que dans tous les journaux il
y a déjà
toutes les statistiques
aujourd'hui à Washington il y a un grand
intérêt de savoir quelle série le pape
parce que le Jean-Paul II a pris une
position très dure contre la guerre de
l'Irak japonais et plutôt favorable
au droit internationaux et qui est
toutes les situations aussi des guerres
soit gérés par l'ONU
et alors il était très contre la
politique néoconservatrice des
Washington alors cette fois là dans
cette élection il y a certainement un
intérêt américain d'avoir un pape moins
disons sur une ligne européenne
et contre la ligne de Washington et
peut-être qu'il essayait d'influencer
aussi l'élection pour avoir un pape plus
moins dur
à l'ambassade de France Jean-Philippe
Thielle et profite de la nuit pour
rédiger au calme ses rapports à l'Élysée
tous les jours tous les jours dans ce
cas précis on fait un point sur
ce qui s'est passé au Vatican
il est 22h15 les questions matérielles
qui ont occupé l'intégralité de ma
journée sont réglées avant celles qui se
poseront demain et là on prend un peu le
temps pour pour dire à Paris dire au
gouvernement aux autorités ce qui s'est
passé dans la journée le Vatican c'est
important d'un point de vue
relation internationale le
géostratégique c'est important d'être
bien avec
c'est pas un objectif en soi mais
quand le Vatican dit quand le pape dit
et non mourir des ponts et non des murs
avec une claire condamnation du mur
du mur de séparation entre Israël et
Palestiniens c'est une condamnation très
forte
lorsqu'il dit non à la guerre alors que
peut-être que l'effet le contrediront
mais c'est une position très forte donc
oui c'est important d'avoir de mesurer
nos convergences
qui entendent ce message exactement
voilà
bon alors cet article 36 de la
Constitution postale
c'est dans les coulisses on spécule sur
le nom du prochain pape dans la rue
c'est une autre rumeur qui court dans
quelques heures la dépouille du pape ne
sera plus accessible au public c'est à
cet instant qui arrive Marie-Aude 31 ans
une jeune femme venue de Paris avec
trois amis
on va prendre la queue
elle a 14 heures de train dans les
jambes elle est catholique très fervente
et elle a déjà rencontré Jean-Paul de
personnellement à trois reprises
est-ce que vous savez combien il y a de
d'heures de queue
Deezer
[Rires]
on nous annonce 15 heures de
cours
on est là pour ça c'est à dire moi ça
m'embêterait de dormir demain
de vénération finale il y a une nique
aussi
à cet instant ils sont encore 400 000
dans les rues de Rome venus du monde
entier ils sont tous exténués et cela ne
fait que commencer
a de l'autre côté
les jeunes Parisiens ne verront pas la
dépouille du pape ce soir Mario et ses
amis ne renoncent pas pour autant après
trois heures de sommeil l'aube s'annonce
les derniers seront les premiers Mario
n'a plus qu'à se laisser guider vers le
corps du Saint-Père
c'est une ambiance sereine et puis
surtout on est conscient qu'on fait
partie des derniers à pouvoir voir les
affaires et du coup ça nous aide à tenir
le coup
[Musique]
il est 6h30
dans quelques heures la dépouille du
pape ne sera plus accessible au public
une demi-heure plus tard veille des
obsèques c'est notre dernière chance
d'obtenir un entretien avec les
cardinaux électeurs la plus haute
autorité du Vatican a exigé qu'il cesse
de parler de la succession de Jean-Paul
II au média pas de quoi faire frémir le
vieil arbre d'Abidjan le cardinal agréé
toujours d'un tel cardinal parce que il
était ceci parce qu'il était cela les
journalistes
la Grèce il y a déjà des articles un tel
sera pape et puis il est rentré à
gazanian s'appelait et puis quand il est
sorti il était cardinal
quelquefois
en mettant des gens déjà pape et puis
ils en sorte
aujourd'hui une réunion plénière doit
les rassembler tous pour la première
fois pour mettre au point les derniers
préparatifs des funérailles
Monseigneur lustigé et Monseigneur
honoré eux aussi ont accepté qu'on les
accompagne mais le duo est bien rodé il
va falloir s'y reprendre à plusieurs
reprises avant d'obtenir une réponse
claire sur la succession de Jean-Paul II
en attendant la réunion a lieu à 10h et
Rome est totalement congestionné
à travers un dédale
on va passer par la probablement
Monseigneur Barbarin lui a choisi
d'aller à pied
bonjour bonjour madame et lui aussi
accompagné
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme ça
et puis
on va à pied jusqu'au Vatican comme ça
un petit peu
x
responsabilité
et une seule chose à faire à laquelle il
faut bien réfléchir pour laquelle il
faut beaucoup prier avant
malgré les consignes de silence chaque
clan chaque sphère d'influence rassemble
ses troupes et affiche clairement ses
convictions le prochain pape sera-t-il
l'homme d'une église de liberté ou au
contraire conservatrice tous vont tenter
une dernière fois de convaincre que leur
choix n'est pas animé par des
considérations politiques
pour ne pas l'emprisonner ce pauvre pape
qui va venir dans le moule de Jean-Paul
de ce serait vraiment
à l'école le droit des hommes oui
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'il soit
exactement la même chose c'est comme si
on demandait à Chirac d'être comme
Mitterrand c'est pas juste
moi je vois pas du tout un autre
Jean-Paul II sur rue sans botterasquer
pour l'Église un Jean-Paul II casquet et
beauté une allusion au clan des
conservateurs qui intriguent en
coulisses une grille de lecture que
Monseigneur lustige et lui rejette en
bloc que le patron qui choisit le patron
est pour nous c'est Dieu
donc c'est difficile de faire un profil
de faire un profil de poste
en réalité c'est bien des choix nous
sommes toujours tentés dans
les fatihams
[Musique]
nous nous n'en parlons pas parce que les
cardinaux ont demandé hier aussi qu'on
ne parle pas du futur pape et qu'on ne
parle pas du conclave donc je n'en parle
pas je crois que les hommes sont tous
des hommes et que dans le cœur d'un
homme il y a aussi celui d'un enfant un
amour de toujours un amour qui
n'arrêtera jamais quel que soit les
circonstances et aussi un amour qui
meurent s'aidera à rien mais ne nous
trompons pas ne nous trompons pas par
exemple du 20e siècle qu'est-ce qu'il y
aura plus d'importance Jean-Paul II ou
Mère Teresa bah vous en savez rien
et le nom de Jean-Paul II restera non
pas à cause du fait qu'il a été un pape
à Rome avec des foules etc restera à
cause de sa santé vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire ça pour moi c'est une chose
que l'histoire prouve énormément le
monde entier connaît ça François
d'Assise saint François d'Assise c'est
lui qui nous a donné les crèches qui ont
été le chemin de la croix
[Musique]
pour les cardinaux en voiture c'est à
100 m de l'axe ça se passe il est 9h55
porte Sainte-Marthe
embouteillage de calotte rouge et de
berline nous avons passé une première
fois les portes de la Cité interdite
dans la voiture de l'ambassadeur cette
fois c'est celle du cardinal Lustiger
qui nous permet de franchir la frontière
en portée par sa verve retrouvée
Monseigneur ne s'en aperçoit même pas
c'est pas l'élection du président des
États-Unis ou du président de la
République française
c'est pas le même système
on n'oublie pas la même logique voilà
on a donc besoin de silence on a besoin
aussi de se purifier le cœur l'esprit le
jugement
pour essayer de voir à peu près
les cardinaux ont besoin de silence cela
n'empêche pas bien entendu les
conciliabules à peine arrivé à la
réunion préparatoire cette fameuse
congrégation prélude au conclave les
évêques français n'ont qu'une hâte se
retrouver
mais là nous sommes instamment priés de
rester à l'écart
au même moment à l'ambassade de France
auprès du Vatican c'est le branle-bas de
combat tout le monde est requisitionné
le président Chirac arrive ce soir à
l'ambassade où il passera la nuit outre
l'hébergement du couple présidentiel
l'ambassadeur et responsable de
l'accueil de toute la délégation
officielle qui vient de France et aussi
des Français de Rome toute l'ambassade
est sur le pont
en ce qui concerne l'arrivée des
cardinaux le cardinal penfu arrive en
voiture cet après-midi
et cardinal honoré n'arrive pas à le
joindre
les services de sécurité de l'Elysée
débarque Pierre Morel à l'oeil surtout
vous allez un petit bureau
outre les cinq sièges réservés à la
délégation officielle l'ambassade a
obtenu 150 places assises pour les VIP
de la France
jardinage et cuisine diplomatique les
places ne sont pas numérotées il faut
donc arriver très tôt à la cérémonie
pour pouvoir constituer un carré France
qui en impose aux autres délégations
pour la secrétaire de l'ambassade
l'horaire du rendez-vous est délicat à
annoncé
il faudrait être là
5-6 heures du matin
5 6h du matin 5h du matin très vite
c'est l'inquiétude l'horaire très
matinale risque d'en dissuader plus d'un
alors que dehors on se prépare déjà à
camper dans l'ambassade Pierre Morel
convoque une réunion l'ambassadeur doit
être sur maintenant de pouvoir occuper
tous les sièges réservés sinon il perd
la face et la France aussi il faut
occuper notre place si vous voulez c'est
pas on n'est pas là pour
pour ce côté mais dès lors qu'on a le
sentiment que bon il faut quand même
être présent
et en même temps il faut que les gens
tiennent parole on peut pas voir un
carré vide ou des un carré clairsemé si
on est donc on a fait un effort pour eux
la contrepartie c'est que bon ils
viennent on change pas d'avis le
personnel de l'ambassade des mobilisé
ils vont partir à 5h du matin place
Saint-Pierre pour essayer de constituer
un carré VIP français honorable bien
volontaire mais qu'est-ce que je fais
mon vélo moteur je laisse ou après je
dois maintenant je reviens pas ici
mais pour faire passer la pilule de la
marche à pied du réveil matinal et
remercier les nuits blanches
l'ambassadeur a prévu un petit cadeau
qui arrive
ouais
[Musique]
7 minutes là on est en place il y a les
carabiniers tout le monde est là
Pierre Morel s'en revient de l'aéroport
où il est allé accueillir le président
de la République
le couple Chirac dormira ce soir dans la
résidence de l'ambassade
mais avant une courte nuit de sommeil
pierre Moret l'offre à ses
collaborateurs une poignée de main
si vous voulez bien jouer mes
collaborations
pour eux d'une semaine de préparatif
bienvenue à la maison
[Applaudissements]
c'est parfait
lendemain matin une heure avant le début
des obsèques alors que l'équipe de
l'ambassade est déjà depuis longtemps
sur place au Vatican Jean-Philippe
Thiais Satan à partir avec la délégation
officielle problème elle part sans lui
la [__] cérémonie parfait pour le
protocole mais pas pour la course
impeccable dans son sprint il réussira à
saluer le président dans la foulée
avant de sauter dans le bus
direction Saint-Pierre
chez les cardinaux c'est aussi le grand
jour
c'est comme ça qu'il faut être comme ça
soyez pas méchant comme d'habitude quoi
réveille douloureux et moins
protocolaire dans les rues de Rome
[Musique]
un quart d'heure avant la cérémonie le
père Max gloupet pénètre à l'intérieur
du périmètre des invités notre mini
caméra s'est invité elle aussi
bien plus loin les yeux rivés sur les
écrans géants Mario et ses compagnons
ont oublié leur fatigue des dernières
heures
[Musique]
qui est à côté de lui
la place de Max gloupet est réservée aux
premières loges de la cérémonie
il rejoint les évêques à droite
[Musique]
à gauche les officiels italiens sont au
premier rang un peu plus haut les
représentants musulmans
à l'heure où le cercueil est amené sur
la place
70 chefs d'État ont fait le déplacement
l'instant est exceptionnel
la cérémonie est présidée par
Monseigneur Ratzinger 77 ans doyen des
cardinaux et l'un des favoris des prêts
à conservateur pour succéder à Jean-Paul
II
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre mini caméra passe la frontière de
la Cité interdite sous le nez du garde
suisse Georges bouge cette éclipsé très
vite mais le président Chirac ça tarde
en coulisse
premier impression sur les obsèques au
cardinal Lustiger
tout à fait et une magnifique
organisation de la région
diplomatique pour que le cardinal honoré
s'engage et représente les intérêts de
la France lors des congrégations des
cardinaux c'est justement le corps du
Nord
c'est une succession des forces
ça vaut la peine cinq cardinaux français
sur 117 c'est peu le cardinal honori est
un atout de plus pour faire entendre la
voix de la France
en tout cas le cardinal retraité se fait
prier l'ambassadeur insiste encore une
fois
je sais mais on retrouvera toujours des
relais cette cardinal entre il y aura
toujours des relais on est là pour ça
mon cher ami comment ça va c'est gentil
d'être venu
j'ai compris que c'était très bien passé
avec l'Iran
finalement le carré VIP français s'est
reconstitué presque naturellement autour
de Jacques Chirac détendu comme à la
maison une claque dans le dos d'un
ministre allemand une poignée de main à
une ministrée chez les bouches
une tête connue qui traverse l'écran
[Musique]
la diplomatie française au travail comme
on ne l'a jamais montré
une dernière photo souvenir avec Lula le
président brésilien et les autres amis
de la France
lui aimerait bien serrer la main du
président c'est difficile mais il a un
allié de poids Jean-Philippe remis de
son sprint du matin
de Saint-Louis
auprès de mon Seigneur Ricard Jacques
Chirac ne guerre intéressé madame prend
le relais
Lustiger nous a dit qu'il allait
grave Saint-Louis
surprise au milieu des robes rouges un
turban noir le président iranien
le président iranien c'est fou quand
même la pape on prend la mesure de son
importance ça dépasse les chrétiens
c'est celui qui
qui a visité le monde pour essayer de
faire avancer la cause de la paix
et qui a été très attentif aux problèmes
orientaux
élémentaire
cette vérité
une dernière question à Monseigneur
Barbara enfin connaisseur des médias il
va tenter la petite phrase qui fait
mouche lorsqu'il aperçoit notre caméra
et c'est pas important de ne pas se
faire de souci pour ces
obsessions parce que si vous voulez
chacun sa grâce donc à partir de mon où
il est élu là je suis resté à Grasse ce
sera bon
parce que imaginez que ce soir attire ce
que j'ai vu la 77 ans ça durera peu de
temps ce mec là il est absolument
lumineux il a rien à voir avec Jean-Paul
II mais il est lumineux une nouvelle
fois mon Seigneur ne peut s'empêcher de
parler de ses collègues cardinaux
pour lui j'ai rien à voir avec lui ma
faute les derniers mots avant le silence
du conclave
le pape le plus charismatique du XXe
siècle sais-tu à jamais
place au souffle de l'Esprit Saint
et ils sont nombreux ceux qui se porte
volontaire pour l'aider dans son choix
[Musique]